[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à bruxelles ici
au parlement européen c'est parti pour
30 minutes d'actualité on débrief ce
premier tour de la présidentielle
française avec mes invités avant de les
présenter quelques chiffres l'europe
respire emmanuel macron contre marine le
pen c'est donc la fiche du second tour
de scrutin de cette présidentielle une
campagne inédite qui a tenu en haleine
toute l'europe
24 01 % pour le candidat dans marche
mouvement lancé il ya maintenant un an
ici à bruxelles et dans les capitales
européennes dimanche soir ce fut un
énorme soulagement le candidat pro
européen est en tête marine le pen elle
signe une belle performance en se
hissant au second tour 15 ans après son
père avec 21 points 30% des suffrages
exprimés 7,6 millions de voix donc on
débrief ce premier tour avec mes invités
un club de la presse étrangère qui vont
pouvoir nous dire comment cela est perçu
depuis bruce l'allicine et depuis les
capitales européennes
jean quatremer bonjour bonjour on ne
vous présente plus vous êtes le
correspondant de libération ici à
bruxelles et vous signez se livrent les
de l'europe aux éditions
calmann-lévy un guide à l'usagé des
eurosceptiques nous en dirai plus tout à
l'heure quentin arias bonjour vous êtes
journaliste au site d'actualité
européenne politico et vous étiez
dimanche soir chez jean luc mélenchon
j'ai bon c'est vrai mais c'est bien ça
lorenzo consoli bonjour vous êtes
journaliste italien vous travaillez pour
l' agence à skynews bienvenus enfin que
nous de priest vous êtes journaliste
allemand et vous couvrez donc
l'actualité européenne pour les journaux
du chum que media group font de ce média
gros fous qu'eux mais des hommes que
media group j'ai été bercé normalement
messieurs emmanuel macron marine le pen
au second tour est ce qu on a évité le
scénario catastrophe que notre prise
pour l'union européenne
on a évité le cas tu as la catastrophe
immédiate
certainement mais si alors on a gagné
une bataille
si on
mais on n'a pas encore gagné la guerre
gagner la guerre c'est le premier pas
d'un nom marche une longue marche pour
emmanuel macron pour emmanuel macron
évidemment l'analyse et pas seulement
pour huit jours toute l'europe et
surtout pour l'allemagne pourquoi parce
que c'était le candidat en fait que
l'allemagne voulait voir arriver parce
que pour l'allemagne
d'abord que le candidat le plus pro
européen a gagné c'était comme vous avez
dit un grand soulagement parce que pour
l'allemagne ça constitue par deux
raisons d'état d'être pro européen et
populiste chez nous sont assez faibles
les grands partis sont tous en consensus
et il faut continuer avec le projet
européen
et cette idée du ni droite ni gauche qui
était portée par emmanuel macron c'est
quelque chose qui a une résonance en
allemagne tout à fait mais on a on a
aussi un basé sur la sur le tandem
franco-allemand et il faut le ressuscité
et ça est une défi pour l'allemagne
aussi en lorraine va consoler en italie
comment ça a été perçu emmanuel macron
c'est quoi on et dont le voit comme le
matteo renzi français il ya un peu cette
tendance
je crois que il y a comme un des grosses
différences le problème qu'on a eue nous
avec matteo renzi c'est qu'il n'a qu'il
a été très bon sur la réforme le
rajeunissement de la classe politique
c'est de là mais il était très divisé
ses candidats en france les clients
il y à diviser énormément son propre
camp son propre parti mais emmanuel
macron elle est perçue comme un affront
par contre je crois que kirui qui a un
gros mois au départ il est rassembleur
c'est quelqu'un qui a réussi quand même
à rassembler la gauche à droite à gauche
à droite au centre
il a réussi aussi à se présenter comme
une alternative crédible à même à la au
système actuel dont il a été carrément
partie parce qu'il a été un ministre
ils économisent donc ça a été ça c'est
la chose franchement que que je ne peux
que je considère la femme s'améliorait
au site parce que c'est pas facile c'est
faire un billet que c'était aussi un
produit si ce n'est pas facile
jean quatremer le fait que le fn soit
finalement en deuxième position c'est ça
la surprise
oui on aurait pu même espérer qu'ils
soient éliminés du premier tour parce
que la démonstration était faite que le
front national n'était pas forcément
qualifié d'office
si françois fillon n'avait pas eu ces
problèmes judiciaires auraient vu un
fillon macro un fillon macron tout à
fait républicain c'est à dire que la
présence du front national au second
tour n'était pas obligatoire il faut se
rappeler quand même que marine le pen
était parti espérait avoir 30% des voix
en février dans les sondages la
donnaient à 28%
elle termine à 21% et fr pourquoi elle
termine à 21% parce que je pense qu'elle
s'est elle a fait une très mauvaise
campagne en l'accent sur la sortie de
l'euro et de l'union européenne
il n'y a pas de majorité en france pour
une sortie de l'union européenne et de
l'euro d'ailleurs la dernière semaine de
campagne est revenu à ses fondamentaux
l'immigration les musulmans la sécurité
etc
donc ça c'est vraiment le vieux fn qui
est ressorti le vel d'hiv et à la rafle
du vel d'hiv laquelle les français
évidemment n'ont joué aucun rôle un nom
n'était pas l'école à bord n'a pas
collaboré nous les français c'est bien
connu et
elle est revenu à ses fondamentaux la et
même chose c'est mélenchon mélenchon la
dernière semaine il explique alors on
vous avez mal lu mon programme en fait
je veux pas du tout sortir de l'euro et
de l'union européenne a ses attaches et
en fait à leur ouïe a cité la mauvaise
campagne parce qu'en fait les deux ont
cru enfin ont surestimé la volonté des
français de sortir de l'union crois que
les français en réalité se méfie de
l'union mais c'est un contrecoup de la
méfiance à l'égard du système politique
français c'est une victime collatérale
cibler l'europe par rapport à là où la
crise politique intérieure alors c'est à
dire quant à ariès que comme certains
ont pu le dire notamment dans les
éditoriaux au niveau européen que c'est
un coup d'arrêt pour les populismes en
europe
c'est la quatrième potentiel élections
qu'ils perdraient bas on sait pas quand
après l'autriche après les pays bas
on va avoir le second tour après la
question c'est un truc mais pour que
bruxelles soit rassuré faut absolument
que macron gagne bien et confortablement
ci-après pas faire ce qui n'est pas fait
pour l'instant il ya encore si on
additionne les voix du conte aignan de
mélenchon de le pen
on peut rajouter à ce lino et chemine à
ce qu'ils veulent on arrive presque à la
moitié des camps des voix des électeurs
français qui sont un peu perdus et dons
qui peuvent répondre au populisme au
pour l'instant on attend ce qui va se
jouer dans ce second tour d'après vous
c'est quoi c'est un référendum pour ou
contre l'union européenne tout puisque
vous en pensez à lui d'allemagne oui
pour deux de la perspective à le monde
c'est clairement un référendum sur
l'europe mais tel le principal clivage
de cette campagne en plus un oui mais je
je je peux bien croire et ça harmonise
avec la perspective à le monde que les
français la majorité des français
restent résolus à continuer avec le
projet européen
ouais vous êtes sûr jean 80 parce
qu'après tout on voit bien que et
quentin nous l'expliquait à l'instant on
a quand même quasi un électeur sur deux
qui est dsk était intéressé en fait par
un projet potentiellement euro
sceptiques voire europhobe
on a parlé fréq site quand même on est
quand même sur les fractures du
référendum de 2005 on n'a toujours pas
réglé
vous avez raison les fractures sont
toujours là bon on peut toujours se
consoler en disant qu en 2005 c'était 55
% pour le non et l'a finalement les
partis eurosceptiques ou europhobes sera
moins de 50%
donc c'est déjà un peu rassurant alors
maintenant au second tour là je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec nous tu sais
que là on a 2 2 deux projets de société
totalement différent qui s'opposent ça
permet de vérifier les choses on a un
projet néo fasciste face à un projet
républicain un projet de fermeture face
à un projet d'ouverture à plonger anti
européen face à un projet européen donc
là les français vont pouvoir dire
clairement ce qu'ils veulent lorenzo a
mon avis oui c'est un fan en pro contre
l'euro mais c'est aussi j'y crois là
dans les prochaines mois la dernière
chance pour l'europe parce que il faut
absolument pas oublier une fois que
macro aura gagné comme tout le monde
s'attend comme les sondages pour une
fois on a eu raison la raison d'agir en
france alors il faut il faut pas penser
que une fois que macro aura gagné on a
résolu le continent via la boîte
anciennement que les premières quand
même un vrai rôle en italie en italie il
y avait beaucoup d'autres pays il ya
énormément de gens qui sont contre la
façon dont laquelle le nouveau
générateur zone euro a été gérée et il
ya le problème de la leadership
allemande qui a été un échec et il faut
que la nouvelle
la nouvelle leadership française soit
capable de répondre de reprendre la kxf
cinq ans le monde avec un protagonisme
des français qu'ils comprennent mieux
mais les vents de general del euros pour
le coup devront en fait se positionner
comme étant capable de faire des
réformes c'est tout du moins ce que
l'allemagne demande avant de commencer à
poser le débat qu'ils réforment docks en
seine que l'allemagne devant alors on a
justement été voir un peu du côté de
chez nos voisins ce qui se disait dans
la presse qui est donc qu'à elle aussi
porte une énorme soulagement tout le
monde s'est un petit peu est redescendu
un peu en pression petit tour d'horizon
avec salomé rousserolles douglas
[Musique]
soulagement général dans la presse
européenne
la crainte d'un second tour le pen
mélenchon écartée c'est le candidat dans
marche fervente europhile qui s'attire
les faveurs quasi unanime les médias
européens en marche vers l'elysée titre
le soir quotidien belge
ce dimanche les français ont fait leur
révolution balayant à la trup les partis
et les hommes politiques traditionnels
pour mettre face à face deux
personnalités hors système souligne
l'éditorial le journal polonais gazeta
wyborcza
salut l'elysée qui se rapproche de
l'europe unifiée en italie les journaux
voient dans le succès des manuels macron
une belle marche d'espoir pour l'avenir
de l'union le mot révolution et même
employé par plusieurs titres de presse
le candidat dans marche est synonyme de
renouvellement pour une partie des
médias européens à l'instar d'el país
quotidien espagnol qui évoque
l'espérance macron un espoir pour
l'économie mondiale pour la zone euro
pour l'europe
pourtant l'arrivée au second tour de
marine le pen est le symbole d'une
défaite de l'établissment politiques et
des fractures françaises peuple contre
élites perdent en contres gagnants de la
mondialisation interventionnisme
économique contre libéralisme sauvage
outre manche le candidat libéral a
séduit la presse
le guardian estime que malgré représente
le meilleur espoir d'un grand pays est
profondément troublé certains médias
étrangers mettent en garde contre la
tentation de l'abstention et la victoire
de la frontiste marine le pen
le quotidien conservateur allemand
frankfurter allgemeine note le caractère
très serré de la victoire de macron et
soulignent le danger que représente la
candidate du front national
outre-atlantique le constat est
relativement partagés en faveur d'
emmanuel macron seule certitude pour le
wall street journal
marine le pen est l'ennemi juré de
l'union européenne et de sa monnaie
unique une monnaie qui a bondi après
l'annoncé des résultats du premier tour
de cette présidentielle
[Musique]
quand ariès quand on voit effectivement
que les marchés ont été eux également
rassuré dimanche à l'annonce de de ce
second tour qui s'annonce entre marine
le pen et emmanuel macron certains ont
commencé à dire bon bah de toute façon
c'était logique
emmanuel macron c'est le candidat des
marchés et c'est le candidat de la bulle
pro bureaucrates de bruxelles
est ce que c'est vrai je suis pas sur
les plus de pouvoir répondre comme ça
non c'est vrai que là la bulle
bruxelloise a quand même c'est la
labilité bas après quand on parlait aux
fonctionnaires aux députés et aux
diplomates ici céreq macron depuis
février il y avait une vraie captive à
sion avec notamment quand fillon a les
affaires fillon vont commencer à
exploser dans la presse auto maintenant
c'est sur la macro c'était vraiment le
choix de bruxelles après on va on va
encore voir c'est à dire j'en veux pas
certains diplomates là depuis lundi se
pose aussi la question des législatives
c'est à dire comment réussir à faire une
majorité parce que berné la faune ainsi
la courbe de 43 de valse pour la loi
travail ou pour la macro qui est aussi
passé au 49 3 n'a pas marché ou du moins
n'a pas été compris même ce sont des
réformes qui sont approuvés par
bruxelles donc la question c'est
maintenant réussir à avoir un consensus
sur ces réformes parce qu'il ya que
comme ça que ça marche compris c'est
quoi la priorité vu d'allemagne c'est la
discipline budgétaire c'est la capacité
de la france à respecter les règles
européennes
oui celle à l'orthodoxie évidemment mais
je pense qu'on a quand même en allemagne
et des doutes là dessus avec emmanuel
macron noah nous voir c'est vrai que le
contrat de confiance entre la france et
l'allemagne depuis des années sur cette
question que non mais comme j'ai dit il
faut que l'allemagne aide un peu
emmanuel macron sur le plan symbolique
mais aussi sur le fond parce que ce
pauvre mec à
un défi qui donc où ses prédécesseurs
ont raté c'était monsieur blair c'était
monsieur schneider qui a perdu son
pouvoir
mach revers qui a réformé l'allemagne
aujourd'hui même les chorales est et
comment il n'était pas réélu donc ils
semblent être des réformes tout en
restant en fait dans une dimension
sociale pour pas casser la machine comme
ça c'est passé justement et gerhard
schröder ont ri en allemagne mais c'est
ça ces fraudeurs étaient trop pro marché
trop libéral trop ni au libéral et la
clientèle sous démocrate détourner de
lui qu'est ce que c'est la priorité pour
la france selon bruxelles jean quatremer
selon bruxelles selon bruxelles c'est la
réforme de l'économie il faut remettre
en marche l'économie française elle ne
va pas si mal ces personnes pour sa
macro est la bonne personne pour ça mais
surtout parce que le gers qui apparaît
aujourd'hui c'est l'existence de deux
france ont sans douté parce que célia
gère effectivement il ya un récit
national depuis des années des années
qui nous montre une france en crise
perdu face à la mondialisation etc
de quoi on s'aperçoit c'est qu'en fait
il ya la france des villes des grandes
villes des capitales régionales qui va
très bien lire marine le pen elle fait
moins de 5% des voix par exemple à paris
12% des voix en allant à strasbourg etc
mais marseille il contrairement à ce
qu'on croit elle n'est pas forte ni dans
les villes ni dans les banlieues dans
les banlieues elle se prend ses prix à
une série de déculottée qui est très
intéressant dans ce qui s'est passé en
revanche elle est forte
là dans les zones qui sont heureux des
zones rurales ou des zones qui étaient
anciennement industrialisés et où la
population n'a pas en soi n'a pas bougé
soit s'est pas adapté quand on calcule
la carte du vote front national sur le
niveau de formation des citoyens
ça correspond plus ou moins vous êtes
diplômé c'est pas d'être chômeur mais
moi vous êtes diplômé plus vous voter
pour l'extrême droite
donc l'enjeu fondamental c'est de
réparer cette fracture et ça passe par
quoi c'est passe par une politique
active en matière d'enseignement parce
que l'enseignement français est un échec
il faut le dire nous produisons entre
mille
jeunes sortent du système scolaire sans
diplôme en france chaque année voilà
vous laisser exactement c'est notre mot
aujourd'hui le taux de chômage chez les
jeunes sans formation il est de 25 %
chez les jeunes pour un diplôme
il est entre 4 et 5% donc c'est le plein
emploi quand vous étiez dimanche soir
c'est jean luc mélenchon justement quels
étaient les demandes va peut-être que
vous avez pu discuter avec certains
militants quelles sont leurs aspirations
parce qu'après tout on voit qu'il ya une
volonté aussi de remonter le niveau une
volonté d'égalité est ce que c'est ça
qu'ils portaient aussi oui il y avait ça
après la question c'est comment sais tu
comment macron avec quelle majorité va
gouverner
voilà c'est une majorité de centre-droit
soit ses marges et de majorité de centre
gauche là après dire que ça va aussi
orienter les politiques à mettre
exactement
par exemple si macron la veut séduire
des électeurs de gauche c'est fou qu'il
parle d'écologie faut qu'ils parlent la
réforme bancaire
enfin pour dans le dos que je moi j'en
ai parlé il faut qu'ils parlent
potentiellement réorienter ac qui part
en europe et social que hamon a pu
porter cette nécessité en fait de faire
de la convergence fiscale et sociale
pour l'instant on l'a pas entendu bas
pour l'instant il assuré travailler
tâche et il suit les réformes de la
commission dessus il parle un peu d'un
parlement de la zone euro il parle un
peu d'un budget de la zone euro après
là on sait c'est du françois hollande
consolidé non non non ça c'est un peu
plus et un peu mieux puisque la
commission a quand même travaillé de ces
derniers temps et ils s'appuient
vraiment beaucoup sur ce qu'elle fait la
commission c'est à dire c'est à dire que
c'est la joue entre guillemets par
rapport à ce que d'autres candidats
étaient sur ce qui se passe ici
après on va voir la question c'est
comment les sujets vous avancez quoi
vous perdez pas de vue une chose c'est
vraiment la réforme de l'europe n'est
pas la priorité de maquereaux la
priorité de macron c'est de remettre la
france sur les rails et de réduire cette
fameuse fracture sociale on n'a pas
réduit depuis 22 ans
alors on a vu en attendant que dimanche
soir tous les dirigeants européens
beaucoup de capitales se sont rués sur
leur téléphone et sur twitter pour
tweeté à quel point ils étaient soulagés
de voir emmanuel macron au second tour
alors petit florilège margaritis finesse
donc est le porte parole de juncker donc
junkera félicite emmanuel macron pour
son résultat au premier tour et lui a
souhaité bon courage fédérer camo
guérini qui a dit voir les drapeaux de
la france et de l'ue eux salué le
résultat d' emmanuel macron c'est
l'espoir et le futur de notre génération
martin schulz je félicite emmanuel
macron maintenant il faut que tous les
démocrates en france s'unissent pour que
la nationaliste ne devienne pas
présidente
le porte parole d'angela merkel sait
bien qu emmanuel macron a eu du succès
avec sa position pour une europe plus
forte et une économie sociale de marché
bonne chance pour les deux prochaines
semaines
etc etc est-ce que c'est pas lui tirer
une balle dans le pied que de voir toute
l'union européenne comme ça à l'unisson
lui dire qu'il n'est pas seul et c'est
bon pour le deuxième tour oui mais
marine le pen il soutenu par vladimir
poutine et par donald ryder qui a
effectivement 8 et vive la victoire
minds nigel farrage qui a un petit peu
racines et des pouvoirs il faut pour
l'accusation d y aurait pas partie de du
camp du camp du front national contre
mâcon 10 ans est le candidat de
l'étranger parce qu'effectivement
c'était le vrai risque est comme ça
arrive de la démarche est d'assurer le
pen et le candidat d'un autocrate russe
est la candidate de d'un type un peu un
peu d'un qui gouvernent les états unis
et le candidat du breakbeat heures donc
là elle peut pas se livrer ses p'tits
pros ces noms là le jeu est perdu
d'avancé est ce que vous êtes d'accord
lorenzo quand je crois je crois que
la vue déjà à rome la dégradation de
rome oui ça là c'était là c'était clair
il faut pas être politique politiquement
correct au niveau de ne pas prendre
position
si l'europe est mis en question par ces
gens là l'europe a le devoir de se
défendre si l'europe est l'objectif
d'une série de calomnies de mensonges
excellent et on doit le dire ce n'est
pas vrai les robes doit défendre les ai
pas beaucoup effectivement l'europe et
les institutions européennes ont le
devoir de défendre l'europe et les
valeurs européennes
c'est absolument clair et c'est une
erreur de de s'abstenir de dire ah non
mais on peut pas rentrer dans le jeu
mais non parce que on est on parle des
eurobonds pas pas d'autres choses on
passe de vous dont vous devenu quant à m
non il ya il ya quand même un danger
encore c'est le débat c'est le débat
mais des bases avec 3 heures c'était dur
comme la dalle à froid dans ce qu'elles
sont c'est à donc hélas après c'est sûr
que ça va être compliqué si par exemple
la question de du support de fin du
soutien de la commission ou 2 x ou y
là après ça va être compliqué a
peut-être tertiaire est justifiée ou du
moins de réussir à travailler donc après
on va voir risque d'être effectivement
la précieuse pour l'instant c'est que la
plupart c'était dans leur langue
originelle ou en anglais donc c'est vrai
que je vais peut-être que les
traducteurs twitter on peut encore bien
marcher 10 à 20 points de différence je
veux dire il faut quand même arrêter
dire tout le monde va dire à tout faire
basculer
ça fait basculer dans un sens à ce qu'on
dit on du potentiel mais un débat là où
ça a joué par exemple c'est giscard
mitterrand là ça a joué parce qu'on
était à 0,1 pour cent et donc les villas
les courbes ne se rapproche pas ne sont
ne risque pas de se croiser et donc je
n'imagine pas une seconde que le débat
puisse changer mais là simplement ça a
été un échange de formule et ça peut
être violent parce que si emmanuel
macron joue bien le jeu du débat il peut
faire exploser en plein vol marine le
pen s'est emparé agressive méchante
comme est apparu jean luc mélenchon le
soir du premier tour où il a fait une
sortie totalement ratée où ils
paraissent vraiment le mauvais perdant
c'est chavez perdant le pouvoir donc
évidemment là d'un seul coup une partie
quand même de ses soutiens étaient un
peu surpris devant tant de hargne
bon en attendant c'est le checkpoint
c'est l'heure du checkpoint de thomas
millions cette semaine thomas s'est
intéressé à une déclaration qu'on entend
régulièrement sur l'union européenne
l'union coûte plus cher qu'elle ne
rapporte alors est ce que c'est vrai ou
est-ce que c'est faux le checkpoint
s'est tout de suite on l'entend souvent
l'europe nous coûte trop cher tout comme
marine le pen ou nicolas dupont aignan
françois asselineau étaient revenus avec
cette idée avant le premier tour de la
présidentielle française
savez vous mes chers compatriotes que la
france donne chaque année 23 milliards
d'euros à l'union européenne et n'en
reçoit que 14 à l'écouté la france
perdrait donc chaque année 9 milliards
d'euros dans l'aventuré européenne
mais tout d'abord quel est l'intérêt de
ce calcul il est assez limité cette
soustraction purement comptable et
réductrice l'action de l'union
européenne se limite évidemment pas à
une redistribution d'argent
les politiques qu'elle mène vite à
élever le niveau de vie de chaque état
membre et à faire progresser ensemble
leurs économies quoi qu'il en soit
quelle est la contribution au budget
européen
il faut savoir que chaque état membre
verse un montant calculé sur base de son
rnb le revenu national brut
autrement dit une partie du total des
revenus perçus par la population de
chaque pays est versée à l'union la
france a ainsi verser 20,6 milliards
d'euros en 2015 année des derniers
résultats
c'est moins que ce qu'a fait m françois
asselineau et cela représente moins d'un
pour cent du rnb français c'est
proportionnellement moins que d'autres
pays la belgique par exemple à verser 5
et 2 4 milliards d'euros soit 1,3 pour
cent de son revenu national brut par
rapport à la taille de son économie la
belgique contribue donc bien plus que la
france mais que donne l'union européenne
en retour
la france a reçu un peu moins de 14 5
milliards d'euros sous forme
d'investissements notamment dans
l'agriculture où le numérique
la différence entre ce qu'elle donne et
reçoit tournerait donc autour des 6
milliards la france donne-t-elle chaque
année 23 milliards et ne reçoit que 14
s'est plutôt fait
toute reprise une réaction peut être
commencer parce qu'il ya la même chose
en allemagne cette croyance que
finalement l'europe nous prend plus que
nous rapporte qu elle nous rapporte
mais ça c'est un calcul extrêmement
simpliste iq et l'allemagne le meilleur
exemple
parce que dans ce chiffre absolu nu
contribuant plus que chaque pays dont
deux dans le mur européenne et c'est
clair en profite on profite et ça n'est
pas représentée par les chiffres comme
ça donc c'est clair qu'on achète avec
l'argent des machines aux aguets
volkswagen mercedes vous des volkswagen
moi mais j'ai demandé à lorenzo vous
êtes d'accord passé une croyance en fait
qu'on retrouve en italie ou pas oui
l'italie est devenue depuis maintenant
plusieurs années un contributeur net
aussi donc il fait partie des pays comme
l'allemagne comme la france l'angleterre
des pays qui mettent plus de ce qu'il
récupère qui récupère et mais je ne
crois pas que personne vraiment pense en
italique qu'on dépense trop pour l'union
européenne on voit à quoi ça sert
l'europe et en italie elle a pensé
longtemps que l'europe était une façon
pour moderniser l'italie
le problème c'est que si tu ce narrative
comme on dit en anglais c'est c'était
vraiment ses narrations à la qui
commence à avoir des problèmes en italie
parce que là la zone euro la mauvaise
gestion de la crise de la zone euro à à
amener les gens à penser que finalement
c'est c'est plutôt quelque chose qui
empêche la croissance devrait au fossé
c'est vrai que maintenant c'est cette
idée de l'europe qui modernise
l'économie qui modernise la façon de
gérer aussi là la politique ni en italie
c'est ça ça c'est d'ailleurs parce que
le chiffre de celle justement l éthique
ou de succès parce qu' il dise des
choses qui sont vraies c'est à dire que
la la la zone euro n'a pas bien marché
solide pour l'italie et la politique
surtout à le monde dansait vite et a
vraiment posé problème pour la police
ali beaucoup plus que pour les autres
pays sauf évidemment la grèce qui est la
grèce qui est dans un autre état encore
mais écoutez merci messieurs de nous
avoir éclairé sur cette question jean
quatremer je rappelle votre livre les
de l'europe très vulgaire matin
qu'elle livre les de l'europe
guide à l'usagé des eurosceptiques chez
calmann-lévy merci à vous d'avoir pris
le temps de nous éclairer sur ce premier
tour la semaine prochaine vous
retrouverez ahmed tazir on se retrouvera
bien entendu pour débriefer le second
tour dans quinze jours ici même très
belle semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]